MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you all for coming.
It is my pleasure to
introduce Jacob Silverman.
I am [INAUDIBLE].
I work in new
business development
here in Mountain View.
Jacob Silverman's
recently released book,
"Terms of Service," is a
call for social media users
to take back ownership
of their digital lives.
Integrating politics, sociology,
pop culture, and technology,
Silverman explores the
surprising conformity
at the heart of the
digital culture,
and what it means now that
none of us can ever be alone.
Reflecting on the implications
of the collapsed barriers
between our private and public
lives, "Terms of Service"
explains how social
media companies
engineer their products to
encourage shallow engagements
and discourage dissent.
Illuminating the new era of
connectivity as never before,
Silverman brings into
focus the inner conflict
we feel when deciding what to
share and what to quote "like,"
and explains how
we can take steps
we need to free ourselves.
Silverman's work has been
published in "The New
York Times," "The Los
Angeles Times," "Slate,"
"The Atlantic,"
"The New Republic,"
and many other publications.
In 2008, "The Virginia
Quarterly Review"
recognized him as one of the
top literary critics under 30.
And in 2012-- this
is the coolest part--
he was a three-time
"Jeopardy" champion.
He lives in Brooklyn, New York.
And I also want to
say a couple words,
because I've known
Jacob for 18-plus years.
He and I went to high
school and college together.
And so I thought, given
that some of his work
is obviously critical of social
media companies, of which we
are included, I was really glad
to bring him here to Google,
because I know that
this is a community that
encourages discourse and is
welcoming of challenging ideas.
And also because I thought
it would be really fun slash
ironic slash potentially
inappropriate
for me to go through
my old emails
and find something about Jacob--
JACOB SILVERMAN: Oh, no.
MALE SPEAKER:
--and then publicly
display it not only
here in this room,
but also for the
YouTube audience,
possibly in favor of
those who he critiques.
And so I went through my emails.
And the interesting
thing is-- so Jacob
and I have been
friends for many years,
and he was, with me,
an early Facebook user.
What's interesting is
that Facebook actually
did a really good job
of having everything
that he ever posted
on my wall removed.
So there was lots of gems in
there, but I couldn't get them.
JACOB SILVERMAN: Because I
deleted my account, you mean?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, because
you deleted your account.
But what I did
find-- and I put this
at the end of your slide deck.
And by sending this slide deck
to me, Google owns it all.
But this was the
first thing I found,
which is Jacob forwarding
me a feature in CNN.com
about what it's like
to work at Google.
And he said, and I
quote, "Looks amazing."
JACOB SILVERMAN:
I was naive then.
MALE SPEAKER: A naive,
aspirational Googler.
And then the second was
actually pretty interesting.
So this is when I
searched "Google Jacob."
And then when I searched
"Facebook Jacob" I got this,
was amazingly consistent
with Jacob's current views.
OK, so without
talking much more,
I'll introduce Jacob Silverman.
[APPLAUSE]
JACOB SILVERMAN: That was great.
I thought it was going
to be more embarrassing.
Hello.
Thanks for having me.
So this is the kind of very
lofty and pretentious title
of my talk, but it gives
you a sense of what
I'm going to be talking about.
I'm going to also be
talking about issues
that are related to my book and
related to what [INAUDIBLE] was
talking about, but
some of the stuff
is sort of new--
or at least, new
for me to be talking
about-- and kind
of a jumping-off point of
where my book has brought me
and some of the issues
that concern me now.
So I'd like to start with
this one, this image macro.
Perhaps you've seen something
like this floating around
on social media
over the last year.
I think it's a
pretty clever setup.
Look at all those people
immersed in their newspapers
and not talking to each other.
With that one line,
"All this technology
is making us anti-social,"
an argument is made.
It is also, I think, totally
wrong and misleading,
but it's a useful
departure point
for considering how we
talk about technology
and our relationship to it.
And I think the sheer popularity
of images and arguments
like this tells us a lot about
how we think about technology
and how we relate to it.
But first, let's
figure out what's
really going on in this scene.
We should start
by narrowing down
what is actually
meant by "technology,"
a broad term that we often
use as a helpful shorthand,
but that can lead us
down some rabbit holes.
Here, technology simply
refers to these newspapers
that everyone is reading.
And newspapers are
technology, or at least,
the convergence of
many technologies
surrounding printing,
production, delivery,
and so on.
Newspapers are such
a good technology
that they've stuck around--
embattled, sure, but not much
different than they were
100 or 200 years ago.
The machines and processes
we use to make them
have vastly improved.
The journalistic
culture has changed.
But newspapers themselves are
rather similar-- newsprint,
ink, some text, graphics.
And newspapers are
tremendously useful things.
They offer the day's news.
You can fold them up and
put them in your bag.
You can swat a fly with them
or use them as wrapping paper.
You can take it in the bath
or give the paper to a friend.
You can write notes on
it and tear out a page
and share it with your kids.
You can stuff the
newspaper in a closet
and 20 years later take it
out, and it'll probably still
be readable.
That's probably not going to be
the case with your smartphone
or laptop.
But what else is going on here?
If I were a more
thorough researcher,
I'd have tried to find out
the provenance of this photo.
But I think it's also
more fun to speculate.
To me it looks like a
passenger or commuter train,
perhaps in the 1940s.
It appears to be an
English-speaking country,
probably the United
States or perhaps England.
The posters at the front of
the car seem to say "FREE,"
and another has a photo of
what looks like a soldier.
That might be a draft poster
or something encouraging people
to buy war bonds, though
because there are so
many men on this train I
wonder if it's still wartime.
We should also note that
there aren't many women here,
nor a single person of color.
This is mostly a
space for white men,
perhaps going to work at
the beginning of the day.
So are these newspapers
making them anti-social,
as that little comment
at the top would have it?
Not really, not in the
sense that newspapers
have their own volition and can
force someone to do something.
In fact, they're probably all
reading the same newspaper,
or from the same
one or two papers.
Print media was pretty
vibrant in these times,
with lots of competition.
That means that
they're mostly reading
about the same events, perhaps
even the same articles,
and in fact have much in common.
What else?
There are limits to how much
close reading we can do,
and we should keep in mind
that every photograph is
in some sense
constructed, and some are
more constructed than others.
There's a degree
of staging here,
something the photographer
was deliberately
trying to capture,
a scene of men
together-- alone, but
also together, as Sherry
Turkle describes it, immersed in
their daily papers and rituals.
So how would the
scene look today?
Maybe something like this.
That image macro
implied that there
was a lineage between
old technologies
and new, occupying similar
places in the social fabric.
Today this photo might be
on a subway or a plane.
This is from Hong Kong, I
believe, with a smartphone
in every person's hand.
It'd be a more diverse
crowd, but the train
would probably be crummier.
This is hardly an era
in which we invest
in public infrastructure.
Soon we'll all be
reading contentedly
in our own private
self-driven cars.
And while today it'd
look like everyone
was doing the same
thing, staring numbly
into the intoxicating glow
of a smartphone screen,
they could be doing
any number of things
with these
multifunction devices.
Few of them, I'm afraid,
would be reading newspapers
on their phones, but who knows.
Maybe these imaginary
people would
be reading news and catching
up on the events of the world,
and not just scrolling
through social media feeds,
watching viral videos,
playing freemium games,
and listening to low bit
rate streaming music.
It's hard to say.
Each person, though,
in this kind of scene
would be wrapped up in his or
her own highly personalized,
filtered world, even
as they all seem
to be absorbed with
the same technology--
a smartphone, today's
universal prosthetic.
If we go back for a second
to the original photo,
one other thing we can
say about newspapers
is that they don't change.
They do decay, but
otherwise they're static.
They won't update with
the next day's news.
They won't push notifications
if something important develops.
They won't interrupt
the act of reading
with an alert of a new
message from a friend.
And they also-- and this
is pretty important,
I think-- won't collect any
information on their readers.
They have ads, but these ads
don't know anything about us.
Newspapers are dumb
analog objects--
not a perfect
technology, of course,
but I think with much to admire.
Those smartphones, on the
other hand, those insulating
technologies that are
supposedly keeping us
from knowing one another,
are always on, always active.
Increasingly, they're
watching us, monitoring us,
trying to decode what we like,
who we are, how we behave.
They're always snitching on
us, ostensibly for our benefit,
but really betraying
our confidence
and, yes, our privacy,
to whoever has
access to the data we produce.
After all, surveillance is the
business model of the internet.
Data is the great resource
and commodity of today,
though in this case
by data we really mean
personal information, habits,
preferences, and the like,
or our "likes," your personal
information and mine.
And the more intimate
and revealing the better,
particularly if
this information can
be gathered over a long
period, giving whoever's
collecting it a picture of
your habits and tendencies.
This pretty excessively
long preamble
is my way of introducing
a few themes for today,
namely surveillance,
data, privacy, power,
and how they affect our lives.
But I also started by focusing
on this photograph here,
because I think how we
talk about technology can
be just as important as
what we say about it.
I have sort of one foot
in the academic world,
and people in academia are
always talking about discourse.
This photograph reflects, I
think, a certain argument,
a certain worldview.
In analyzing it, we come to
understand that technology
is not just something that
lives on its own, that's somehow
ethically neutral
or an abstraction.
A technology is an embodiment
of the social, political,
and economic conditions
in which it's made
and in which it's used.
It often incorporates human
intention and human error.
This is a kind of crummy photo
that someone posted on Twitter,
but it's a photo from a
middle school hallway.
This is a poster,
and that's supposed
to be like a CCTV camera.
Surveillance and data
collection have become central
to our lives and to the flow
of information and money today.
But surveillance isn't benign.
As the law scholar Frank
Pasquale says, surveillance
is not just a camera,
but an engine driving
society in a certain direction.
He's right, and
it's worth thinking
about what that direction is.
Surveillance is
generally coercive,
instrumentalist, designed
to discover something
or to preserve a
state of affairs.
When we're aware
of surveillance,
especially when we come to
understand that the things we
do and say are being fed into
systems that potentially shape
our future experiences--
where we go,
what we see, what
opportunities we have,
whether law enforcement
decides we're a threat--
it alters the relationship.
It potentially introduces a
kind of dissonance, a feeling
of self-consciousness.
Perhaps if you're a student who
sees this poster walking down
the hall, I'm sure it might
put you a little ill at ease.
But it's a
self-consciousness that's
difficult to contend with,
because so often there's
nothing we can do.
Think about how you might
feel when a cop pulls up
alongside your car
or you notice a bank
of CCTV cameras in a store.
Suddenly your attitude, your
manner of being in the world,
shifts.
You're on notice.
We live in a culture
of surveillance,
but what does that mean exactly?
It's not just about
these processes
of monitoring, collecting,
sorting, and data mining.
Surveillance is something
that's done to us,
and it's something we do.
So we watch reality TV.
We set up cameras in our homes
to monitor children, pets,
or babysitters.
We broadcast our
lives on social media.
We take videos of
cops because we're
worried about how they may
treat someone they're wrestling.
We establish online
profiles and update them
so that we might
never feel invisible.
We watch and are
watched all the time.
This is how we often think
of surveillance these days.
This is a panopticon,
in this case part
of an old prison in Illinois.
Michel Foucault said that
the panopticon wasn't just
quote, "a dream building.
It is the diagram of
a mechanism of power
reduced to its ideal form."
The 19th-century political
philosopher Jeremy Bentham
designed the panopticon
as a kind of ideal prison.
Guards stand in the
tower in the middle.
A ring of cells
surrounds the tower.
Prisoners can see
the tower and have
the feeling of being
watched, which is supposed
to check their behavior.
But in an ideal
panopticon, they can't tell
where a guard might be looking.
The prisoners are totally
transparent to the guards,
while the guards are
opaque, shadowed, hidden.
Sounds to me a little like the
relationship between citizens
and government today, or between
consumers and tech companies.
But the panopticon metaphor
is a bit worn-out, simplistic.
It's used all the
time now, and it's
perhaps time to move beyond it.
I think it doesn't quite
capture the fullness of what's
going on, nor how highly
distributed and variable
surveillance has become.
Rather than living
under the unforgiving
gaze of a panoptic,
Orwellian society,
it's more accurate
to say that we
live in a state of constant
possible surveillance.
This is why Kafka, not Orwell,
is the great writer for today,
though Orwell has
plenty to recommend him.
In Kafka's work, power
is obscured, hidden.
We're aware of its presence
and its effect on characters,
but often only too late.
In Kafka's work, power
presents itself suddenly,
brutally, and mysteriously,
sometimes using
surveillance in the process.
This kind of disembodied
floating power
always lurking just out of
view is a helpful framework
for studying today's
surveillance culture.
I just love that photo.
Kafka was for much
of his adult life
a lawyer with an
insurance company.
He essentially was a
bureaucrat, and had
a sense of how power could be
wielded by opaque institutions.
Today, we deal with all
kinds of bureaucracy,
often to our own frustration,
and often of a familiar sort.
But I think software represents
a new kind of bureaucracy.
Algorithms act as
the bureaucrats,
making decisions based on
inscrutable, or secret,
criteria, and we, the users,
act as data producers and nodes
and feedback loops
that increasingly
shape our surrounding world.
Consider this passage
from an article describing
a maker of smartphone games.
And I've got a long quote here.
"GSN does not simply track
customers preferences
and customize its
services accordingly,
as many digital businesses do.
In an effort to induce players
to play along or try more
games, it uses the data it
pulls from phones to watch
for signs that they are tiring.
Largely by measuring how
frequently, how fervently,
and how quickly you
press on the screen,
the company can predict with
a high degree of accuracy
just when you're likely
to lose interest,
giving it the chance to
suggest other games long
before that happens.
The games are free, but GSN
shows ads and sells virtual
items that are
useful to players,
so the company can persuade
someone to play"-- oh,
excuse me-- "so the longer the
company can persuade someone
to play, the more
money it can make."
End quote.
So essentially what we
have here is this company
GSN, which makes little
gambling and poker apps
and things like that.
It's tracking what people do,
how they respond, and sort
of trying various
prods and nudges,
and perhaps even changing
the parameters of a game,
to try to get someone
to play longer.
That's from an
article about what
are called persuasive
technologies, technologies that
try to get us to do
something-- perhaps
with our own consent, perhaps
arguably for our own benefit,
like a fitness monitor that
prods its owner to sleep more.
But of course, these
persuasive techniques
first and foremost
help the bottom lines
of the companies behind them.
And even that fitness
monitor, to take one example,
might be trying to get me
to sleep more because it's
cut a deal with
my health insurer
and my employer that,
in exchange for us
wearing fitness monitors,
we'll achieve certain health
benchmarks, fork over
more personal information,
and save the company some
money in health costs.
These so-called
persuasive technologies
offer more visible
manifestations
of how power operates in
networked digital systems.
And even these are only visible
because they're reported on.
And in some cases, companies are
so proud of their innovations,
of their ability to
persuade, that they're
willing to disclose
how they work.
But most people playing
GSN's games likely
have no idea that
they're essentially
being coaxed and herded
toward desirable behaviors,
all with the goal of keeping
them on the platform.
Excuse me, I'm getting over
a little bit of a cold.
The type of power we're
talking about here
is invisible and mysterious.
And that's what I think
makes it so confounding.
That's what makes it difficult
to talk about, to regulate,
to protest, to argue over,
to defend, to legislate,
and on and on.
We have to make
it visible first.
We have to learn how to describe
it and articulate its contours.
There are many other
possible examples
of these sort of
persuasive technologies,
or of this kind of
hidden movement of power
that I'm talking about.
Some of them may be
familiar to you--
ads that show up in
pivotal moments in games,
call center software that gauges
customers' emotional states
and sorts out the
possible troublemakers,
online retailers that
employ differential pricing
software, that offers
a different price
for each customer
based on personal data
and the software's judgment
of what they might pay.
I have to apologize for
the next slide, but.
Or you might recall that
Facebook got in trouble
last summer for releasing the
results of a study in which it
manipulated the content of
more than 600,000 users news
feeds to show happier
or sadder content.
The company wanted
to know if it could
induce certain emotional
states in users,
and then see those emotions
travel through the network.
And for people like me,
who study the tech industry
with a kind of
disturbed admiration
at its influence
over customers, it
was an unnerving experiment--
not only because Facebook
seemed to think that it
had done nothing wrong,
but because these
kinds of experiments
go on all the time in secret.
And of course,
Facebook never asks
the users who are involved
in the study for consent.
It's presumed based
on their accepting
the terms of service agreement
that they had already given it.
Indeed, the fact that these
experiments go on all the time,
that's what OkCupid founder
Christian Rudder told us.
Quote, "We experiment
on human beings,"
he wrote on OkCupid's blog.
Continuing the quote,
"If you use the internet,
you're the subject of hundreds
of experiments at any given
time on every site.
That's how websites work."
It was troubling to see
Rudder being so enthusiastic
about this state of
affairs, but he's
correct at least in one sense.
Many tech companies are in the
behavior modification business.
That this represents the status
quo doesn't make it ethical.
It also doesn't mean that it
can't change for the better.
Frank Pasquale, who
I quoted earlier,
calls this world the
black box society,
a place where surveillance, data
collection, sorting algorithms,
and related systems exert
a peculiar kind of control.
This kind of control may be
based on millions of A/B tests,
reflecting the kind of
experimentation that
so excites Christian Rudder.
Or maybe utter pseudoscience,
but with a patina
of mathematical precision of
the unimpeachable authority
of a computer.
The TSA, for instance, has
spent more than $900 million
tracking the behavior
of human beings
in airports across the country.
The idea is that
would-be terrorists
might be spotted by noticing
certain telltale tics,
as if finding a
terrorist in a crowd
is like spotting a
poker player's bluff.
A number of studies have
found that these techniques
are utterly useless.
Supposedly revealing
signs like someone
who's visibly nervous or
sweating, or asking a few too
many questions, are
common to many travelers,
but that hasn't stopped the
TSA from pouring resources
into this and other similarly
crummy programs, most of them
based on saturating our airports
and various transport networks
with CCTV and surveillance
and facial recognition
and all sorts of forms of data
collection and data mining.
But after all, this is why
it's called security theatre.
The authorities must be
seen doing something,
even if it's an utter waste.
And who knows, perhaps
advances in facial recognition
and other forms of
biometric monitoring
will soon render all this moot.
Would-be terrorists
will be spotted
because an algorithm decides
that their style of walking
looks suspicious,
or that they spent
a few seconds more than the
average traveler lingering
around the security area.
It's through this
kind of logic, which
I think in some ways represents
the logic of big data,
that some behaviors
become normalized
and others criminalized.
Like the internet,
airports increasingly
represent personalized
filter bubbles,
where different demographics
and even individuals
are assessed and sorted
according to obscure criteria
that's never shared with them.
This is how we get black and
brown people randomly selected
for additional inspection,
interrogation, and suspicion,
while whites and other
privileged populations
are allowed to smoothly
pass through pre-check.
In other words, the
black box society
affects different populations
in different ways.
Here's one stark example.
I hope you'll pardon my
crude graphic skills here.
Here we have two opposite
approaches to networked cars.
At the top you have a tweet
from Elon Musk describing
how owners of a
certain Tesla car
were going to receive
an over-the-air software
update to an inverter
algorithm, and it's
going to make the acceleration
0.1 second faster.
On the bottom
here, this is taken
from an article about these
interrupter devices that
are put on cars for people
who get high interest
loans in order to afford cars.
And I see here two opposite
approaches to networked cars.
Those who can afford
expensive Teslas
receive over-the-air
software updates that
improve the car's performance.
It seems like a great
deal, this promise
of incremental periodic
updates for your car,
though maybe we should be
wary of cars that increasingly
act like computers, that
basically are computers
with engines attached.
Soon enough, they'll
be accumulating viruses
or refusing to drive because
we haven't installed the latest
firmware update.
But for now, I guess, this
must seem kind of cool.
In the second example,
subprime lenders
cajole buyers into
accepting devices called
startup interrupters, which
can be activated remotely
to shut down the car
if the borrower is even
a day late on a payment.
Many people who take this kind
of deal have little choice.
They need a car to
get to their job,
or to take their kids to school.
They're often from
low-income backgrounds,
so they accept the
29% interest rate
and the mysterious
interrupter device
that's planted in their car.
Some of these interrupters
are also geofenced,
meaning that the car might be
shut down if the driver goes
out of a designated area.
The lenders and repo men
operating the interrupter
software have a real-time view
of everywhere a driver goes.
They know when she goes to work.
Or, in the case of one
Texas driver who had her car
shut off, when she
leaves her geofenced area
to go to a shelter to find
refuge from an abusive husband.
In this woman's case, the
lender shut down her car
and sent a tow truck to
repossess it while she
was still at the shelter.
Others have had their cars
shut off before their loans
actually go into default,
during family emergencies,
or even while driving
on the freeway.
What unites these
examples-- and in fact,
what I think is a defining
feature of the black box
society and of a world
in which software
acts as a new form
of bureaucracy--
is the difficulty of appeal.
Who can you ask for help,
for some understanding
or accommodation or relief from
standard operating procedures?
Even when it's possible to
talk to real human being,
that person can always point to
the terms of service agreement
or the mechanics of the
software to remind the customer,
this is just how it is.
You're stuck.
These kinds of arrangements
are endemic to what's
been called the sharing economy.
On Gigwalk, a jobs marketplace
like Mechanical Turk
that assigns tasks
through smartphones,
workers who don't respond
to tasks within 30 minutes
are penalized.
This fact is unadvertised, which
makes it even more difficult
for workers who may not
realize why they're not
getting the kinds of tasks
they were being offered before.
Not long ago, I took a
car through Hailo, a taxi
through Hailo, to take
my cat to the vet.
It seemed like a
pleasant enough cab ride.
I tried to apologize
for my cat's meowing,
and the driver
didn't seem bothered.
But then as I stepped
out of the car,
I noticed him give me a
rating of three stars.
Since then, when I
open the Hailo app
I'm told that there
aren't any cars available.
Is it true?
Are there no drivers
in my area anymore?
Or was I downgraded in
the app by that rating
and now drivers are
refusing to pick me up?
It's hard to know, and
I probably never will.
So, goodbye to Hailo for me.
Obviously, my situation
pales against that
of a Gigwalk worker
or sharing economy
labor, who face these kinds
of dilemmas constantly.
Uber drivers are let
go after their ratings
fall under 4.6 stars.
They're not fired exactly.
After all, they're not employees
in any legal sense, which
has been key to Uber's growth.
The app simply deactivates
their accounts,
meaning that they can no longer
earn money driving for Uber.
What can a driver do but
accept this arrangement,
or go work for a
competitor who probably
has similarly abusive policies?
In the end, power
lies with whomever
is controlling the app.
One of the problems
I mentioned earlier
is that when we're dealing with
computers and other machines,
we often assume that they can
do no wrong, that whatever
information or result they
produce is the correct one.
A calculator never lies.
But it doesn't take much
digging to understand
that automated systems reflect
the biases, intentions,
and social conditions
of their creators.
Latanya Sweeney, a
computer scientist
and Harvard
professor, discovered
this when she ran a
Google search on herself
several years ago.
The ads that appeared
next to her name
were mostly offers for criminal
background checks and to look
up her criminal record.
Sweeney had no
criminal record, so she
decided to do some digging.
In fact, she conducted a study,
with some funding from Google,
and found that traditionally
black names like hers
were 25% more likely to yield
ads for criminal records
than were white names.
Now, there are many
possible explanations
for what was going on there.
It could be the fault of
a programmer or Instant
Checkmate, which bought the ad.
It could be that racist
users of Google search
more often click on
arrest records of people
with black-sounding names.
There are many
possible explanations
that it might not even
be possible to isolate
a single factor.
Ad systems are pretty
complex, as you all
know better than I do.
But the difficulty of
knowing exactly what happened
is a major part of the problem.
In the meantime, we
can see these kinds
of biases and blind spots
cropping up all over.
A study by scholars
at Carnegie Mellon
found that women
searching job sites
are shown fewer opportunities
for higher-paying jobs
than men are.
In England recently,
a female pediatrician
was trying to get into the
locker room at her gym,
and she found that
the keypad on the door
wouldn't recognize her pin.
She later learned that the
keypad software was programmed
to only recognize
men as doctors,
and this woman had checked a
box on the gyms sign-up form
to indicate that
she was a doctor.
In one sense the software
was acting correctly,
trying to bar a man, or
what it thought was a man,
from accessing the
women's locker room.
But obviously, because it was
programmed to only recognize
doctors as men, it had been
programmed in a sexist manner.
Earlier I mentioned
data as a new commodity.
It's what allows our
semi-automated surveillance
society to function.
In practice, data acts
something like a fluid, I think,
ending up in often
unexpected places.
In 2013, Latanya Sweeney,
the same Harvard professor
I just mentioned,
devised this map,
showing where
health data travels.
As you can see, it's a
vast but loose network,
and many of the holders
of this data arguably
have no right or
reasonable use for it.
One of the points that Sweeney
has made is that maps like this
are incomplete, offering only
a partial sense of where,
in this case, medical
data might end up.
But I think that she
also would propose
that this process of
mapping, of discovery,
of trying to make these networks
visible, is just as important.
This idea of circulation,
of data as something
that flows through systems
and networks, is key.
Where data flows,
power does as well.
But this idea
isn't entirely new.
If data is a commodity,
then think of it
as just another form of money.
And these days, money is just
another form of information.
It all flows through
the same pipes.
The flow of money
and information
has long been central to the
functioning of capitalism,
but the journey hasn't always
been so smooth as it is today.
Here's Karl Marx,
writing in 1858,
quote, "Capital,
by its very nature,
drives beyond every
spatial barrier.
Thus, the creation of
the physical conditions
of exchange, of the means of
communication and transport,
the annihilation
of space by time,
becomes an extraordinary
necessity for it."
This, I think, is the great
achievement of the internet,
altering the physical
conditions of exchange.
As Marx might have
described it, the internet
annihilated space and
time as impediments
to the flow of capital
and information.
Or at least, the internet
has nearly achieved that.
High-frequency
traders, for instance,
are always trying to
shave another pico
or nanosecond off their trades,
whether by moving their servers
closer to Wall Street or hooking
up to a fiber optic cable
that offers their information
an ever so slightly straighter,
quicker path to its destination.
This is a map of world
telegraph lines in 1875,
around the time that
Marx was writing.
And the reason I
think why Marx was
able to make this
kind of insight
was not just because
he was smart,
but because he also
lived in the early days
of electrical networks.
By 1858, when that
quote is from,
telegraph lines
were transporting
news and information around the
world with a previously unheard
of speed.
They were collapsing
the barriers of space
and moving us closer to a world
in which the speed of light
would be the only limit
on the flow of capital.
Before the telegraph, the
movement of information
was limited by the speed of a
steamship, a horse, a sailboat,
or person's feet.
Though, as James
Gleick has shown,
some savvy people found ways
around these physical barriers.
In West Africa,
indigenous communities
long used drums to communicate
over long distances,
to transform information into
something intangible that
could be transmitted through
the air, through sound itself.
It's really a kind of
remarkable innovation.
There, the speed of sound
and the density of air
limited how far
information could travel,
but there were ways
around that, too-- say,
by having an adjacent community
act as a kind of relay,
taking in the message
and rearticulating it,
retransmitting it, to
the next tribe over.
The same thing was
done in other times
in other parts of the
world, with smoke signals
or by lighting beacon fires
to announce the arrival
of an invading army.
One of the great
innovations of the internet
was to take information,
chop it up into the packets,
send them out, and reassemble
them at their destination.
But in these
pre-industrial communities
you can see similar
techniques at work,
filtered through the
technologies of the time.
Let's get that back to Marx
and this idea of circulation.
As capital flowed
through networks,
Marx saw it
transforming, sometimes
representing money, sometimes a
commodity, sometimes something
else entirely.
As the writer Jonathan
Crary noted, quote,
"This was hardly a one
time transmutation.
For with each successive
upgrading and expansion
of these networks, new forms
of fluidity and convertibility
emerged."
End quote.
This is one of the achievements
of the Industrial Revolution
in the decades that followed.
The telegraph network was
joined by wireless telegraphy,
the telephone by radio
microwave satellites.
Before the rise of
AT&T, some small towns
had their own
telephone networks,
which connected a few
homes or entire community
but when no farther.
Some banking networks
still run on old mainframes
and use COBOL, a
programming language
that's nearly 60 years old.
These networks continue
to operate in parallel
to our own internet.
In fact, I'd argue
that if we step back
and look at all these various
networks, all these ways
of transmitting information,
as a flow, that we've
been blinded by the internet.
We've become
enchanted by this idea
of one monolithic global network
through which all information
must travel.
Following the
Snowden revelations,
some countries have
started requiring companies
to store customer data
within their borders,
or have begun investing
in what might be described
as country-wide intranets.
Increasingly,
commentators worry about
the so-called balkanization
of the internet.
It's being broken up as
new barriers are introduced
to the once smooth flow
of capital and information
across borders.
But if we think of the internet
as simply the latest, and not
the only, network
transporting information,
we might not fear this as much.
We might even say that this
internet, our internet,
isn't as great as it could be,
and that it might even be worth
replacing.
We might also begin to question
whether the unimpeded flow
of data is all that
it's cracked up to be.
Perhaps there are some places
we don't want our data to go.
Perhaps there are
some types of data
that should be
difficult to find,
that should become obscure
or disappear, forgotten.
I'm not the first to come
to this kind of conclusion.
Evgeny Morozov argues
that there's actually
no such thing as "the
internet," which he
likes to put in scare quotes.
And I've become
increasingly sympathetic
to this kind of view.
Not only are there many
information networks,
some of which are
linked together
in what we call the
internet, but each of us
increasingly has a singular
experience in relation
to these networks.
Our own experience is
composed of our filter bubbles
and personalized
services, our specific
journeys through difficult
and sometimes overlapping
bureaucracies.
The Internet, too, is simply
is a shared set of protocols,
and one might argue that the
World Wide Web, the hypertext
transfer protocol,
should be considered
its own network apart from this
thing we call the internet.
By taking this
view, by unbundling
these various
networks, I hope we
can look at them anew
and learn something
about the relationship between
the flow of data and the flow
power.
These days it's
fashionable to look
at our global
communications networks
and think we've achieved
something momentous,
that perhaps, in the
parlance of Silicon Valley,
the world is being
made a better place.
But this is a dream
that has followed
every advance in communication
since time immemorial.
Guglielmo Marconi, a
pioneer of radio-- one
of those pivotal networks of
yesteryear-- said that quote,
"The coming of the wireless
era will make war impossible,
because it will make
war ridiculous."
When I hear Mark Zuckerberg
say that Facebook
is a tool for
advancing world peace
or that internet connectivity
is a human right,
I hear the hopelessly
naive bombast of Marconi.
This is a map of
global shipping lanes,
which I think also
has the appearance
of a kind of network.
What the internet
has achieved, then,
is to enfold people
more closely together
in networks of communication,
capital, and exchange, and more
recently in systems of
monitoring and surveillance.
This is no small thing, but I
don't think it's a revolution.
It's merely an incremental,
if important, step
beyond the kinds of
communication networks
that inspired Marx.
What I think we need,
then, is to understand
what this world of data-driven
surveillance and automation
that I spoke of earlier
truly represents.
Where other speak of convenience
I see the surrender of control.
Where others speak of
personal liberation,
I see the same faded
dreams of emancipation
that have dogged every
industrial epoch.
Where others find a
new kind of sociality,
I worry that we are giving
out some essential form
of autonomy.
But the advantage of this
point, I would argue,
is that it doesn't
treat the internet
and our new digital
technologies as magical.
It grants them no credit,
simply because they
seem special or novel.
Instead, it proposes that,
in our relentlessly digitized
world, people are struggling
with the same challenges
of discrimination, politics,
economics, labor, and the right
to live life as one chooses.
None of that will
go away because
of the advent of a new device
or a new way of communicating.
The world is still
hopelessly mediated,
despite all the talk these
days about disintermediation.
With new platforms and corporate
powers replacing the old,
there are simply new
middlemen that we may not
recognize as middlemen.
The great hope of
some true believers
is that the screens
in our hands,
our cars, our offices,
and practically everywhere
else, will be replaced by
something even more seamless,
as the digital becomes
not an overlay, not
some isolated network,
but perfectly entwined
with the physical world.
Call it pervasive computing,
ubiquitous computing,
augmented reality, ambient
computation, whatever you like.
We'll be able to call
upon networked interfaces
wherever we desire.
They may even be
implanted in us,
or perhaps we'll simply
be content to wear them
on our wrists, which
have become the latest
site of digital mediation.
Jonathan Crary, commenting
on such a utopian prophecy,
had this to say,
quote, "If and when
such devices are introduced
and label as revolutionary,
they will simply be
facilitating the perpetuation
of the same banal exercise
of nonstop consumption,
social isolation, and
political powerlessness,
rather than representing
some historically
significant turning point."
End quote.
In other words, they
too will be replaced.
Today's remarkable gadget
is tomorrow's e-waste.
The human drama remains
largely the same,
though we may be more
distracted from the main event.
It's a dark point of view, but
I find a weird kind of optimism
in it, the sort of
optimism that puts people
before their devices.
If we accept that all these
products and systems are
disposable, fated to become
so much techno trash,
what does that mean?
Perhaps it tells
us that people are
capable of more than we think,
that data shouldn't be mistaken
for knowledge, and that our
digital shadows reflect us
but aren't us, and so we
shouldn't let them define
our experience in the world.
Finally, it may give
us pause on this,
our long march toward a
society in which no one is
left alone or unmonitored.
There we can catch
our breath and say,
our technologies aren't
driving us apart,
but they aren't quite
serving us, either.
And maybe out there
lies some better way
of being hidden behind
the algorithmic curtain.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so we
have some time for Q&A.
AUDIENCE: I was curious
what you would recommend
we do to be safer, more
secure, or just smarter
about our own digital lives.
JACOB SILVERMAN: Well,
frankly, being here at Google,
I fear you guys could tell me
more than I could tell you.
People ask me this stuff a
lot, and I find it challenging,
because there's certainly
stuff you can do.
One of the things
I write about a lot
is the ad-driven
surveillance economy,
which bothers me a lot-- which
is, we have to acknowledge,
the main source of revenue here.
So I do things like
I use ad blockers,
or often use a VPN,
occasionally the Tor browser,
things like that.
And I think there are these
kind of technological tools
to mask your
identity, if you want,
or kind of cover up
the amount of data
you might be leaking towards
whoever might be watching.
On the other hand,
I'd really rather see
that we find new business
models and new kinds of systems
are created that aren't
so dependent on monetizing
the raw material of people's
daily lives and who they are.
And one reason why I
also-- I mean, I certainly
don't mind recommending specific
solutions to individuals--
but why I also talk a lot
about regulation and kind
of government
intervention of some sort
is because I think that we
have these ethical impulses.
We want these services to be
as useful and amazing as they
can be.
But we also want
people to feel safe
and protected while using them.
And I think the
virtue of regulation
is that it sort of takes
that ethical impulse
and establishes it as policy
that can help everyone.
And a lot of people really
don't have the time, resources,
or education to deal
with this kind of stuff
or to even really worry about,
oh, is information about me
being put into some
credit report that's
going to used against me
at a future job interview?
Most people would never
know that even happens.
AUDIENCE: Do you feel that
the surveillance that's
done without people knowing
is in itself unethical,
and how that
compares to the fact
that that's being
done for profit?
And so just to put
it another way,
if you could imagine someone
in a position of power
using information
about people's habits
and knowledge about psychology
to inject certain articles
into people's streams,
that could potentially
reduce racial tensions
between two different groups
or have some benefit to
society where they're not
trying to profit from it?
But it's being done using
these same kinds of techniques
that they're being
done in secret.
They're not
transparent about it,
but they're being done
for a different reason.
Would you find
that is unethical?
JACOB SILVERMAN: I don't know.
I think that is one of
those sort of hinge cases
that would leave me
open to saying perhaps
that's totally fine.
I mean, what people like me
in the world of journalism
worry about, with an example
kind of related to that,
is Facebook has so much power
as pretty much the homepage
of the internet for
a lot of people,
as by far the biggest driver
of readers to news articles.
And for a long time, people have
worried that Facebook really
privileges bad content,
and then they kind of
got rid of a lot of that, a
lot of the click bait stuff.
But then it seemed, and they
really just released a study
about it, that political
content-- especially
about current events, things
like the riots in Baltimore--
were not showing up
enough on people's news
feeds, and perhaps
were being suppressed
by the newsfeed algorithm.
But the problem
is, what do we want
from something like Facebook?
If Facebook were some
nonprofit company that
had a more public-spirited
mission that says,
we want people to be
informed, so we're
going to filter all this
information on their behalf
and kind of decide what
they should be reading
and what might be
important to them, that's
a little different than the
current Facebook we have,
which is this giant for-profit
monolith who, of course, mostly
cares about people
staying on the platform.
To kind of go to your broader
question of can data collection
surveillance be used
for the public good,
I think in some ways it can.
I think sometimes, though,
it's in very basic methods.
And this isn't even
a nonprofit purpose,
but you have
companies that track
how many people go through
intersections and things
like that.
And that seems like
something really basic,
but that's actually really
important for urban planning,
or for someone who wants to
start a restaurant somewhere
or something like that.
And you're not
storing data on who
people are unless you link that
up to some facial recognition
program.
But you are kind of
using similar techniques
and processes for something that
can potentially help people,
but also won't create
this permanent data trail
or associate them with
something that they don't
want to be associated with.
AUDIENCE: As someone who's
trying to design experiences
for people, which may
hinge on this content-- so
your example of Uber-- or sorry.
A different service, where
you didn't see any more cars
and it was not transparent
to you what was being shown,
do you think that
you would you be
OK with that kind of decision
on the part of the designer
if it was at least
transparent what was going on?
JACOB SILVERMAN:
It's a good question.
I think I would appreciate it
more, certainly, if I knew,
look, you're not getting cars
because your rating is kind
of low, or something like that.
If there were some sort
of transparency, yeah,
I think I'd probably
appreciate that.
Though I do think in the
case of a lot of these apps
and the ways the
sharing economy works
is that you are required to make
these very brief assessments
of people or ratings that can
often prove very consequential.
So I kind of think that
that whole rating system
is flawed from the outset.
On the other hand, though, I
think this idea of transparency
is good.
A lot of people talk
about this, especially
in the academic world.
They talk about transparency,
or making these systems legible.
I use the term visibility
a lot, but they
have to be legible
somehow in order
for us to know
what kind of power
they are exerting over us.
And the problem, I think,
and the problem I have even
when giving this kind of talk,
is that a lot of this stuff
is still very new, or
these types of power
can be very hazy.
And the difference
between someone exerting
some sort of control or
influence on you or someone
really helping you,
it can be a fine line.
You don't always
really know, right?
We're kind of in this
murky territory where,
am I giving up some essential
kind of personal autonomy
by kind of giving myself
over to these systems?
At times it does feel like it,
but perhaps in other situations
it doesn't.
And I think something
that can make people
more comfortable with
not only giving over
personal information
but with delegating
that kind of power
autonomy is if they really
know how the processes work.
Of course, there are always
concerns about trade secrets
and things like that, but
I think there's definitely
room to be more transparent and
to tell users more about how
these systems work.
[APPLAUSE]